the average person has to realize what i
started to say
very vigorously last summer and i was of
course resoundingly mocked for this
this isn't going to blow over we're
either going to push it out of power
or it's not going to get out it's going
to continue
we there is no letting it blow over it's
not going to blow over it so you have to
decide what you want to do with that
not everybody is going to be the person
who stands up and
speaks at their their school board but
you can be the person who makes that
person dinner
you know not everybody is going to be
the face not everybody's going to take
the risk
but you can be the person who offers
moral support who you know
creates a network but the most important
thing then for people to realize
is this is a lesson that i learned
watching people stand up to
absurd covet policy is that courage
begets courage
and cowardice begets cowardice it's a
two-sided street
or two-sided coin when you see so
there's this video it went around i
don't know if i could find it again
easily on twitter
and i think it's in canada but maybe it
wasn't there's a bakery or a shop or
something and you know the health
inspector comes in and
or whatever the covid cops come in and
they're hassling them and finally this
one guy says
you're trespassing you need to go and
everybody's kind of cowering and then
second one guy spoke up the whole crowd
starts yelling you gotta go you gotta go
you gotta go
and they ended up you know leaving and
it was it's the most blatant
demonstration i've ever seen that
nobody's speaking up everybody kind of
shied everybody's getting kind of
bullied around
the second one person spoke up a crowd
erupted and that's one other thing if
you're afraid to be
the person who's going to inspire the
courage that begets courage
i jumped off a cliff man you jumped off
a cliff
we didn't know where we were going to
land right now if you jump off
the edge it's not a cliff it's a stage
and there are hands ready to carry you
yes right and people need to understand
that the ground swell against critical
race there it's tr the biggest
trend on twitter right now as we were
just saying a minute ago as the time of
the taping
it's huge it is a hot issue it's 85
95 depending on where you are red or
blue
issue for most people in most
jurisdictions right now of
get this crap out of our schools so the
you have every reason in the world to be
courageous and you're courageous is
going to be infected
infectious on the other hand if you're a
coward
other people see your cowardice and
either somebody's going to step up and
be courageous
instead of you and you get no you did
nothing respectable
or it's just going to encourage more
people to stay silent more people to
keep their head down more people
to hope oh maybe it'll blow over and i
don't have to take a risk
um but that's not what's going to happen
it's either going to get pushed out
or it's it's going to kill us if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell